some people believe that smashing a
bottle of fizz is good luck groom Alexei
serif doesn't ouch
this is a classic case of something
going so wrong it becomes right why did
the bottle of bubbles go ballistic the
theme of this video is that this guy was
unlucky if the bottle had hit the wall
any other bit first it would have
smashed instead of the bottle smashing
against the concrete structure it
manages to impact right on the core the
cork is realy compressible which means
it can absorb all the energy of the hit
without breaking the bottle the bottle
contains wine which has had carbon
dioxide gas forced into it under
pressure to make it a fizzy drink
so once the cork is out that gas wants
to expand rapidly and when it does that
bottle becomes a rocket with all of the
wine and guys shooting out of one end of
the bottle in one direction the bottle
gets thrusted back at him in the
opposite direction
if he hadn't managed to turn around at
the last second that champagne could
have caused some real pain but to be
fair the bottle was acting in
self-defense